patronat-syndicats une première
négociation à blanc la direction de
renault annonce la mise en chômage
technique de neuf mille ouvriers de
flins à partir de demain 14 heures
hubert bonaldi ne sera plus directeur de
la prison de la santé
il répond en exclusivité aux questions
de claude sérillon le sahel malades de
la sécheresse pour le sauver d'une
solution planter des arts
mais messieurs bonsoir renault tout ce
nouveau difficile de savoir si pour
autant la france va s'enrhumer pour
reprendre la lâche connu j'en est il que
le conflit s'enlise la négociation de ce
matin à flins a donné aucun résultat
et il y a deux heures nous apprenions
que la direction ce juge est contrainte
de mettre au chômage technique pour une
durée indéterminée
neuf mille ouvriers de cette usine de
flins neuf mille ouvriers des chaînes de
montage et ce en raison de la grève
bouchons aux ateliers les grandes presse
c'était voici un mois et demi lorsque
les 900 usd grande presse de flat ont
débrayé et occuper leurs ateliers pour
réclamer notamment le statut d'ouvrier
professionnel
ici on presse les caisses deux r18
c'est le cheval de bataille de renault
ici commence toute la politique nouvelle
de vente et surtout d'exportation de la
régie c'est dire l'importance de cet
atelier
toutes les tentatives de négociations
sur le statut de ces 900 us ont échoué
la dernière aujourd'hui ils sont
toujours en grève toute la semaine
dernière la fabrication avait pu
reprendre sans eux en raison d'un stock
de pressage réalisé par le maîtrisent ce
soir le stock est épuisé
ces deux nouveaux l'asphyxient demain à
14 heures à flat 9000 salariés seront
donc mis en chômage technique pour une
durée indéterminée dit la direction
donc en attendant que celle-ci ou bien
les syndicats prennent une nouvelle
initiative vers une solution négociée
la situation est ce soir complètement
bloquée les r18 n'est plus fabriqué tous
intervient le jour même de l'ouverture
d'une semaine chargée en matière de
négociation sociale des rendez-vous
aujourd'hui aux charbonnages de france
après demain la sncf la sncf où les
conducteurs autonomes sont appelés à une
grève de 48 heures par leurs syndicats
pendant le week-end prochain
négociations aussi dans le secteur privé
40 rendez vous sur les salaires et puis
surtout cette fois ci au niveau
interprofessionnel
une grande première rencontre donc entre
syndicats et patronat aujourd'hui sur la
révision du système d'indemnisation du
chômage pour une fois syndicalistes et
patrons sont d'accord ou presque
il s'agit d'accroître la paire plat part
de l'état une double préoccupation pour
le patronat qui a fixé lui-même ce thème
le négociations
rendre plus juste et plus efficace le
système actuel d'indemnisation du
chômage plus juste car les chômeurs
perçoivent actuellement des indemnités
qui varient de 35 à 90 % de leurs
anciens salaires le patronat dit est-il
juste que les indemnités soit aussi
différentes être licencié pour raisons
économiques ou pour toute autre raison
justifie t'il de tels écarts et puis
créer un système plus efficace
la durée moyenne du chômage tend à
s'allonger constate le cnpn certes la
situation économique explique cela mais
en partie seulement
en clair cela veut dire que le patronat
considère que certains chômeurs en
prennent un peu trop à leur aise
il faut donc dit-il être plus incitatif
rendre plus intéressante la reprise du
travail
et pour cela revenir sans doute sur les
90% alors ne quoi va-t-on parler et bien
de plusieurs hypothèses
par exemple accorder une prime à la
sortie du chômage ou encore pour inciter
à la reprise du travail compenser la
perte éventuelle de salaire cela ce sont
les propositions du patronat les
syndicats qui n'étaient pas demandeurs
ont probablement leur poser la demande
une extension des garanties et un
relèvement des taux mais il est au moins
un point sur lequel patronat et
syndicats seront d'accord demandé à
l'état d'augmenter sa contribution car
l'état qui versait 50 % des indemnités
de chômage en 1968 n'en verse plus
aujourd'hui que 22 ans et ce sont les
patrons et les salariés qui par leurs
cotisations supporter la différence
deuxième réunion cnpf syndicales le 23
juin thème l'aménagement du temps de
travail
cent mille logements réhabilités avec
l'aide des pouvoirs publics et plus de
500 millions de francs affecté à
l'aménagement des villes
c'est ce qu'a annoncé michel d'ornano ce
matin à vannes la politique maintenant
avec d'abord toute une série de
résultats à des élections municipales
partielles quelques surprises bonnes
pour l'opposition à flers et à soissons
mais il aura un second tour
bonne pour la majorité a pris en sont ou
ne sont pas là des tas poldi jouer
facilement réélu et à aix en provence
mais là aussi il y aura un second tour
le maire socialiste sortant
félix ciccolini est en position plus
difficile que l'année dernière deuxièmes
têtes de chapitres de ce dossier une
petite montée de sève à propos des
futures élections européennes l'année
prochaine
hier michel debré avait tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé à sa manière une manière qui
n'engagent pas le rpr tout entier fait
on remarquer du côté de jacques chirac
aujourd'hui au nom de l'udf c'est jean
françois deniau qui organise la réplique
je vous laisse entendre l'un et l'autre
d'abord michel debré or il se trouve que
la future assemblée et déjà nommé
parlement ce qui n'est pas prévu par le
traité que la future assemblée sera
maîtresse de sécession quelle sera
maîtresse de son ordre du jour
c'est à dire qu'elle votera sur tout ce
qu'il lui plaira de voter qu'enfin elle
n'a pas été abrogé la disposition qui
permet à l'assemblée de mettre en cause
la commission ce qui donne à celles-ci
le caractère d'un gouvernement de super
état on ne fera croire à personne je dis
bien à personne qu'une assemblée ainsi
livrée à elle-même respectera les
limites juridiques qu'affirme notre
gouvernement
elle sera d'ailleurs aidé par la
commission dont il ne faut pas oublier
les prétentions je crois et je le
regrette que le débat tête que la pause
et monsieur debré est un débat qu'on
mettra dépassé et je crois donc je
devrai se trompe et qu'il se trompe
d'adversaire
le danger n'est plus du tout celui d'une
disparition de nos états au profit d'une
sorte de monstre européen qui serais tu
as un super état vous voulez mettre fin
aux as que la plaie le royaume tandis
eurocrates qu'est ce que ça dit je crois
que le vrai problème est que en dehors
des agriculteurs qui savent très bien
que leur revenu annuel se discute à
bruxelles pour le meilleur ou pour le
pire
en dehors des agriculteurs l'europe n'a
pas d'usagé elle n'a pas de caractère
quotidien personne ne s'en à quel point
de façon concrète cela peut être
important pour chacun de nous
dans quel domaine mais je crois que cela
reste vrai dans le domaine économique
nous avons besoin de la dimension
européenne pour notre activité donc pour
notre niveau de vie et puis enfin je
crois que ça reste indispensable pour la
tête qui était la première idée de la
construction européenne d'empêcher une
guerre entre l'allemagne et la france
notamment comme on l'a vu trop
d'exemples politique toujours avec les
pilotes du conflit entre paris et l'état
la capitale ne s'en sortent pas son
avantage puisque ce matin son maire a
décidé d'augmenter les impôts des
parisiens de 7% afin de financer les
dépenses de police dans la ville
jacques chirac rend le gouvernement
responsable de cette augmentation mais
et christian bonnet le ministre de
l'intérieur avait dit vendredi que le
maire de paris n'était pas du tout
obligé d'en arriver là bref voici
l'illustration un peu spéciale du
conflit que les municipalités peuvent
avoir avec l'état jeudi un peu spécial
car là il ya évidemment un arrière-plan
politique qui n'est pas à négliger
mais cela actualise d'autant la réforme
des collectivités locales dans le scénar
va commencer à débattre demain avant que
l'ensemble parlement n'en soit
définitivement saisi à l'automne
prochain un autre copain
oui cette réforme s'inscrit d'ailleurs
dans les grands dans les grands
objectifs que le président de république
avait fixé au gouvernement en mars
dernier en particulier développer la
démocratie et la responsabilité locale
s'était déjà d'ailleurs l'un des points
abordés par monsieur bart dans le
programme de benoît me suis arrêté avant
le rapport de la commission richard et
puis les visites de monsieur beckham
secrétaires d'état à l'intérieur dans
les communes et la consultation des
maires alors quel est l'esprit général
vient et soul et jusqu'à maintenant
parce que c'est une vieille histoire la
réforme des communes de la réforme des
collectivités locales ce qui est attaqué
ce problème se heurter à une réalité qui
était le nombre considérable des
communes en france 36 milles c'est
beaucoup plus que dans tous les autres
pays et il proposait et des fusions de
communes leur il s'est heurté à une
difficulté c'est il sortait au maire qui
voulait garder leurs responsabilités et
puis au connu de riz l'âge qu'ils
voulaient garder leur personnalité alors
cette réforme n'attaque pas de front ce
problème des fusions de communes
mais il part d'abord de la
responsabilité des maires pour leur
donner en principe davantage de
responsabilités et davantage d'autonomie
ainsi par exemple le numéro rapidement
quelques mesures qui étaient prévues
dans le programme de bois
les maires pourraient déterminer
librement le taux
des impôts locaux les subventions leur
seraient accordés globalement et non
plus secteur par secteur ce qui leur
permettrait de les attribuer eux mêmes
une sorte de smic des communes serait
aussi envisagée pour les communes
pauvres ayant besoin l'équipement enfin
il était même envisagé d'organiser des
référendums locaux mnel d'un même oeil
et lui même qu'ils accordent des permis
de construire eux-mêmes qui ont demandé
l'aval du préfet ce qui n'est pas facile
alors sur quoi va porter la discussion
de nos biens dans un premier temps de la
discussion va porter surtout sur les
questions qu'ils se calment et les
questions financières ce qui est après
tout est naturel c'est lui qui détient
les cordons de la bourse tout si celui
qui détient les rênes au moins une
parcelle des rênes du pouvoir et puis
depuis longtemps c'est là dessus que
s'exprimait le plus vivement le
mécontentement des mers tout récemment à
mercredi
mrs socialiste disait que s'il
n'obtenait pas satisfaction sur le plan
financier le reste serait du bla bla bla
mais à travers et au delà de ces
discussions financières il y voit un
problème de politique générale pour
devenir un problème de société qu'est le
problème de la diffusion des
responsabilités jusqu'au pouvoir central
peuvent ils accepter la décentralisation
et jusqu'où ce qui est localement
veulent des responsabilités sont ils
prêts à assumer toutes ses
responsabilités
jacques chaban delmas lance un appel à
l'unité des français il l'a fait tout à
l'heure à salon de provence en
inaugurant une route jean moulin il faut
at il dit assuré la présence universel
de la france morales culturelles
économiques et s'il le faut pour la
craie militaire afin de désigner au
peuple les chemins de la liberté
hubert bonaldi directeur de la maison
d'arrêt de la santé appelé prochainement
à de nouvelles fonctions il deviendrait
chargé de mission auprès du directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire
c'est l'une des suites les plus
spectaculaires de l'évasion de jacques
mesrine de cette même prison le 8 mai
lui barebone a dit qui par ailleurs est
secrétaire fédéral de force ouvrière
s'il n'exprime pas partout c'est très
nettement un sentiment d'injustice est
ce qu'on aime percer une certaine
amertume
s'agit-il pour la notion centrale de
profiter au sens large du terme de
l'expérience de l'homme de terrain
ou s'agit-il au contraire d'un limogeage
à la vérité en tant que directeur d'une
prison je suis soumis et
réglementairement soumis à la hiérarchie
de mon ministère et on m'appelle à
d'autres fonctions j
et si bonaldi n'y a ni regret ni
amertume dans vos propos il y a
incontestablement un peu ce sentiment
d'inachevé
mais encore une fois je vous répète que
le métier de directeur prison c'est
celui d'un homme disponible et l'aller à
la conjoncture fait qu'aujourd'hui je
suis disponible ailleurs on peut changer
de peau et persévérer en effet dans des
réformes dans des aventures mêmes qui
ont pour infrastructures l'expérience
antérieure et je ne représente rien
sinon que ceux de mes collègues qui
m'ont fait confiance notamment au niveau
syndical
c'est à dire que le départ du directeur
de la santé ne change rien au régime
pénitentiaire
écoutez moi j'espère que le départ du
directeur de la santé n'a rien à voir
avec les épisodes vous les déboires où
les disgrâces des événements que il
s'inscrit vraisemblablement dans un
sentiment ou dans des opinions plutôt
délibérée de réformer la l'institution
pénitentiaire si l'on veut bien
m'inscrire dans cette dimension
alors je ressuscite ray la politique
étrangère maintenant avec d'abord la fin
provisoire de la crise belge qui semble
se dénouer comme cela se passe souvent
chez nos voisins le gouvernement s'est
succédé à lui-même avec la même
coalition les mêmes une niche de même
programmé le même premier ministre lê
huu thinh de manse le roi baudouin a
tout simplement refusé à l'émission et
tout le monde semble d'accord
la réunion de l'opep les ministres
exportateurs de pétrole ont décidé de ne
pas augmenter le prix de l'or noir
on a donc prolongé de six mois à genève
le gel des prix instauré l'année
dernière enfin le proche orient avec des
perspectives de paix qui s'éloigne la
réponse de malembe guina jimmy carter
sur l'avenir de la cisjordanie a le
mérite d'éviter une crise au sein du
cabinet israélien mais un entretient
l'ambiguïté quant au sort de ce
territoire très disputé après avoir tenu
le conseil des ministres le plus long
est sans doute
difficile depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
béguines peut être éviter une crise
gouvernementale mais évitera-t-il la
colère des américains
après la réponse qu'il vient de le
renvoyer sur l'avenir de la cisjordanie
on sait en effet que carter avait posé
comme préalable à la poursuite de la
négociation sur la paix qu'israël
fournisse des éclaircissements sur
l'avenir de la cisjordanie
la réponse de begin la voici autonomie
administrative dès la conclusion de la
paix puis cinq ans après on discutera
éventuellement de la suite voilà en gros
la proposition de béguines pas un mot
sur les palestiniens
la résolution 242 ni sur l'évacuation de
la cisjordanie
en fait ni béguines ni son gouvernement
ne semble décidé à céder un seul pouce
de territoire
aucune solution est donc possible à
moins que les américains ne se décide
cette fois à l'imposer américain le
général john woo l'administration carter
a décidé de ne pas porter l'appréciation
public sur fait répond on fait
l'ambassadeur américain à tel-aviv à
consulter très rapidement messieurs
begin et ayane on savoir si la position
israélienne est aussi inflexible que le
let apparaître le communiqué on dit
aussi que monsieur carter pourrait cette
fois proposer un plan de paix aux
parties en présence
avec ce que certains experts
souhaiterait un nouveau voyage de
monsieur vance dans la région par les
états unis sont inquiets devant le peu
de cas et des palestiniens dans la
réponse que tel aviv le sahel de nouveau
dans l'actualité on ne le sait pas
beaucoup mais la saison 77 a été presque
aussi catastrophique que celle des
années 60 13.14 la même sécheresse la
même famille la même détresse
plusieurs campagnes de sensibilisation
commencer car nous autres européens nous
sommes interpellés par ce drame
la chanteuse nicole rieu vienne sortir
un disque sous l'égide de l'association
française pour le respect de l'homme un
disque que l'on peut se procurer auprès
des guichets du crédit agricole et de la
banque du crédit coopératif et notre
collaborateur jérôme hergault vous
présentera très prochainement sa vision
du sahel 78 il y vient de rentrer de là
bas aujourd'hui et a extrait quelques ce
qu'on ne sent portage voilà le spectacle
que huit pays d'afrique francophone jour
d'hui le sahel une zone composée de
l'erythrée au sénégal par huit pays le
sénégal bien sûr les îles du cap vert la
gambie la mauritanie le mali la haute
volta le niger et le tchad
une catastrophe déclenchée par la grande
sécheresse de 73 74 un drame à l'échelle
d'un continent
80% des arbres sont morts les trois
quarts du bétail ont été décimées cent
mille personnes seraient mortes pour des
raisons liées directement à la
sécheresse
le bilan de cette catastrophe est donc
extrêmement lourd aujourd'hui encore les
conséquences n'ont pas disparu d'autant
que l'année dernière la saison des
pluies a été pratiquement inexistant le
dg le désert dans cette région progresse
à pas de géant
d'une année sur l'autre il avance de 1 à
10 kilos un peu partout le sol meurent
les arbres meurent les habitants s'ils
le peuvent fuient vers d'autres cieux
plus cléments
voilà donc le constat sans intervention
rapide et sans une prise de conscience
des gouvernements locaux
le phénomène sera irréversible la vie
risquent de disparaître sur une surface
du globe aussi grande
presque aussi grande que celle de l'or
amérique vous avez passez donc plusieurs
jours au milieu de ces populations à
nouveau à ça mais alors comment les gens
réagissent t-il sur place
écoutez il ya d'abord eu une prise de
conscience l'échelon des gouvernements
locaux qui sont rendus compte que face à
des climats métérologiques aussi
épouvantable il fallait prévoir l'avenir
et c'est ce qu'ils sont en train
d'essayer de faire et puis il y eu une
prise de conscience aussi et surtout au
niveau international dz se sont
manifestés de toutes parts d aide sous
la forme d' aide alimentaire financière
ou technique malheureusement ce ne sont
que des palliatifs la désertification
dans cette partie du monde est un mal
chronique contre lesquels il est
difficile de lutter qui a toujours
existé
ce contre quoi on peut lutter en tout
cas ce sont les traditions les
populations exemple les troupeaux le
bétail pour les populations locales
constituent un bien de prestige et de
contemplation
en fait c'est le nombre qui compte c'est
le plus grand nombre les troupeaux non
ne servent à rien il faut les fixer et
inculquer aux nomades les peuls où les
touaregs des méthodes d'élevage moderne
traditionnel rationnelle et rentable
ensuite des expériences de reforestation
été tenté c'est la seule parade en fait
contre l'avancée du désert ce que les
algériens ont parfaitement compris et
est réalisé avec le barrage vert qui
l'ont fait pour stopper l'avancée la
progression du sahara vers le nord de
l'algérie enfin en sédentarisant les
populations on peut créer une
agriculture permanent des forces de
l'ordre à tous oui bien sûr il faut de
l'eau et de l'eau on en a trouvé à 250
300 mètres de profondeur ce qui n'est
pratiquement en face qui sied presque
rien compte tenu des méthodes mode
deux forages 250 300 mètres là on trouve
des nappes très importante qui pourrait
suffire pour de très très longues années
hélas le goulot existe autour de ces
forages tout est possible la vie est
possible et c'est en fait pour l'instant
en tout cas la seule solution ce sera
long et fastidieux et pour vous donner
un dernier enfin dernier exemple sachez
qu aux îles du cap vert
cela fait neuf ans qu'il n'est pas tombé
une seule goutte d'eau bien vous
retrouve donc prochainement avec votre
reportage complet
le disque de nicole rieu salivant
concerto pour le rêve le reste de
l'actualité à l'étranger maintenant avec
d'abord un nouvel accès de fièvre à
berne confusion ce matin à berlin est un
militaire soviétique est intercepté par
des policiers est allemands au moment où
il volé une voiture pour protéger sa
fuite l'homme a ouvert le feu et les
policiers ont riposté
bilan trois blessés dont un
fonctionnaire ouest allemand l'homme à
l'origine de la fusillade a été
grièvement blessé et arrêté
les cosmonautes soviétiques vladimir
kovin les nok et alexandrine chunk of
ont réussi à s'arrimer sans problème à
la station orbitale sayoud 6 leur
mission étude de la surface terrestre et
de son atmosphère recherches médico
biologiques et expérience technique
vraisemblablement les deux cosmonautes
sont partis pour battre le record de
durée dans l'espace en mars dernier deux
autres soviétique était resté 87 jours
dans cette même capsule sayoud 6
l'ancien champion du monde mohamed ali a
été reçue ce matin au kremlin par léonid
brejnev le chef de l'état soviétique a
exprimé l'espoir que la visite du boxeur
américain contribue au développement des
relations etats unis urss
mohammed ali est en union soviétique
depuis une semaine pour trois matches
d'exhibition
il a surpris les soviétiques par son
sérieux sur le ring comme au kremlin il
ne s'est pas permis une seul crime à
25000 spectateurs au moins pour le
cinquième championnat du monde de course
en baignoire dans le port du cros de
cagnes près de nice
c'est un polonais qui a remporté
l'épreuve individuelle et des allemands
de l'ouest l'épreuve paris qui comprend
les embarcations avaient le choix entre
les rames les voiles la roue bref tout
sauf d'énergie y compris les muscles à
l'exclusion de tout le moteur à l'arrêt
ce temps sur long mais plus sérieusement
l'armement grec a mieux résisté à la
crise mondiale qui a entraîné vous le
savez une diminution du fret maritime
mieux résisté que d'autres
les norvégiens par exemple c'est dans le
caractère même des armateurs leur
origine et leur formation que se trouve
la clé d'un succès persistant qui étonne
vraiment le monde économique
on connaît en france les armateurs grecs
à travers la vie d'un ou deux mètres
ceux qui étaient les vedettes de la
chronique mondaine et bien cette image
la mairie vous allez voir quelques
retouches pour chaque armateur grec
c'est par là que tout a commencé
une barque de pêcheurs dans son île
natale
ayo sandro souci ross quelquefois dans
un îlot perdu des cyclades
puis un caïques c'est caboteur à tout
faire de la mer egée avec à la clé un
brevet de capitaine fondée sur
l'expérience plus que sur l'instruction
quelques économies et la confiance d'une
banque un associé à condition qu'il soit
un proche parent etc l'achat du premier
grand bateau certains ont fait fortune
au cours des dix dernières années
d'autres travaillent le bateau comme ils
disent depuis quatre générations
il y a les gagne petit et les
milliardaires ils ont tous un point
commun ils connaissent bien la mère et
la vie des équipages comme un annuaire
téléphonique il a le nom du sénateur de
l'aude est aussi leur adresse du genre
au pirée dans le monde entier 400
familles d'armateurs grecque cela fait
2000 compagnies maritimes en gens
prudents ils ne mettent pas tous leurs
jeux dans la même coque certains pour
principe de créer une compagnie pour
chaque bateau en cas de faillite ça
limite les dégâts même devenus grands
bourgeois ils sont restés des paysans de
la mer dure à la tâche
âpres au gain un drachme est un drachme
ce qu'il oublie son mal jugé
en tout cas c'est notre jour quand qui
fondée par les autres métiers tout ça
rassure moi la voyez que le banc salle
est programmateur sérieux ne vont pas ou
dans les casinos
s'il vaut ils vont pour ce faire et pour
faire le plaisir pas pour perdre
d'argent à gagner compresseur moi quand
j'ai voyagé au casino mais comment je
vais au lieu de vie dans une boîte de
nuit belge est dur je peux aller pelles
de mille tracts ou 2000 d'aqmi
jadis à 1000 femmes je ne pas être l'une
est avec muffat la ruine
elle est venue quand même pour
quelques-uns de la crise mondiale une
dizaine de faillite depuis 1973 et
autant à prévoir d'ici 1982 pour les
autres qui résistent bien les temps
néanmoins sont difficiles il a fallu
désarmé une partie de la flotte ici
entre le pirée et corinthe 320 gros
bateaux rouille sur leurs amarres en
attendant des jours meilleurs
mais dans l'ensemble la prudence
habituelle des grecs a été payante avant
la crise
ils avaient pour la plupart signer des
contrats à long terme avec les
compagnies pétrolières à tarif réduit
certes mais il jouait la sécurité
ajoutez à cela quelques autres
précautions par exemple 50 % de la
flotte libérienne appartiennent aux
armateurs grecs
aujourd'hui il y à moi de
enfin du travail pour le bateau que deux
bateaux et malheureusement des grecs
ils ont plusieurs bateaux il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'affrontements
vous me donnez un schiste sur les
bateaux oui à presque cinq mille bateaux
supérieur à 4500 tonnes quel est le rend
actuellement de la marine marchande
grecque dans le monde et sous pavillon
grec c'est la troisième est en tout et
en tout c'est à dire si on compte six
que je viens vous dire de bateaux sous
pavillon étranger c'est la première donc
de 52 millions de tonnes boss est
présente la première
les anciens pêcheurs des cyclades
rapporte à leur pays chaque année un
cinquième de ses ressources en devises
et malgré le marasme actuel ils
apprennent à leurs enfants diplômés des
universités américaines
l'art et la manière de travailler le
bateau à la grecque et statistiques
maintenant les amis si impressionnant
moyenne on opère chaque jour de la
semaine
quinze mille français ambiance et sur
ces milliers d'interventions de toutes
sortes 10% au moins ne serait pas
nécessaire alors les français sont-ils
l'objet de ce que la nos confrères
appeler une surproduction chirurgicale
c'est la question que vous pose oui
enfin il faut toujours se garder de
d'alarmé une population entière ça veut
dire que 90 % sont parfaitement
justifiée et que tous les chirurgiens ne
sont pas fous ou malhonnêtes mais ce qui
est vrai c'est que dans les sociétés
occidentales et ça a commencé d'abord
par les états unis et la grande bretagne
on ne perd plus qu'avant on ne perd plus
de tout qu'avant et on peut se poser une
question est ce qu'on est plus dans la
cave en ont donc ça valait la peine de
s'interroger et la sécurité sociale a
fait un jour ses comptes
elle a fait le relevé d'une journée de
chirurgie dans la france entière et à la
regarder la trouver de grandes
disparités entre marseille bordeaux et
puis aussi des modes on n'opère plus à
tel endroit que cathay l'autre exemple
alors je vais vous allez voir les
exemples d'abord sur 10000 habitants à
paris on est deux fois plus opérer qu'à
limoges paris lyon et marseille alors on
se demande qui rétablit au nombre de
chirurgiens
puis la vie qu'on mène la vie qu'on mène
aussi nombreux survient exactement 2 etc
alors vous avez l'exemple on enlève un
nombre d'applis absolument considérable
12160 par jour c'est-à-dire 280 mille
par an 25 % - sondés appendicectomie
douteuses et on pense que 50 % n'étaient
pas nécessaires
or ça tue quand même la proportion de un
pour mille c'est pas grand chose mais ça
fait un par jour au moins on regarde pas
que les appendices alors il n'y a pas
que les amygdales observons alors 500
par jour
alors là le champion et marseille on a
perdu sept fois plus des amygdales à
marseille qu'à nantes et une enquête aux
états unis sera de dire que dans 90% des
cas
c'est sans doute inutile ou douteux
arriva la visite d'hier 3,4 millions de
français ont des calculs mais cinquante
mille français sont opérés alors qu en
réalité 9 sur 10 ne seront jamais aucun
trouble en dehors de ça et ça fait rêver
par une radio enfin les salariés alors
les césariennes les césariennes ont
augmenté de plus de 5% aux etats-unis en
france leurs chiffres augmentent
constamment une part de la sécurité de
la mère et de l'enfant
dans certains cas c'est vrai dans
d'autres on commence à parler aussi de
césariennes justifier alors tout ça ça
fait beaucoup et ça fait cher oui alors
voilà enfin si beaucoup et c'est cher
alors il faut pas s'inquiéter faut pas
s'alarmer outre mesure mais une
opération ça n'est jamais anodin ça
donne une anesthésie qui n'est jamais
anodine non plus et puis ce sont nos
deniers alors faut tout ça tout le monde
doit faire attention évitez la
prévention quand l'opération est bien la
météo pour terminer avec le temps qu'il
a aujourd'hui d'accord moitié nord
éclaircies et des températures en hausse
moitié sud beaucoup de nuages et même
quelques orages le temps qu'il fera
demain maintenant de la bretagne aux
flandres il sera couvert vous allez voir
avec des pluies
cette zone se déplacera ensuite vers
l'intérieur pour donner un temps
variable avec éclaircies
quelques orages surtout l'après-midi de
l'aquitaine aux régions du nord-est
température sans grand changement
dernière édition vers 23h10
vous y retrouverez pierre alain sachez
également qu'en tête de re diffusera
demain à 15 heures
l'émission de question de temps sur le
cambodge qui nous avait été très réclamé
il est maintenant temps de nous séparer
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
et je vous retrouverai de demain avec un
très grand plaisir
merci votre attention et bon soir